okay cool I am genuinely impressed that
people turned up because it's the last
day the last session and some fella
called Troy hunt he's doing a talk as
well I would expect most people who gone
through his talk so I'm kind of feeling
a bit guilty because I'm gonna have to
tell you a story now last night I crept
into Troy's room and whilst he was
hacking somebody's Wi-Fi and doing
things to a pineapple that would make
your eyes water a little security joke
for you I stole his lucky charm
so Troy is currently in his talk
absolutely breaking it his talk he's not
going to go too well because his
favorite lucky charm
he's on my head so I kind of feel a bit
guilty about that but never mind Troy's
a professional I'm sure he will plow on
through
anyways everyone had a good week at NDC
yeah good good everyone tired yeah
can you cope with one more session do
you think good good hopefully they've
saved the best till last
if anyone is sitting next to anyone who
falls asleep
midway through put your hand up we've
got some marker pens we can have a bit
of fun did anyone read my bio before
they came to the talk okay so when you
submit a talk to a conference they may
ask you to fill out a bit of information
about who you are why are you so great
why should we accept you for this talk
so being British selling myself is not a
natural thing so I had a cunning idea of
going to Twitter to ask people to write
my biography for me obviously I've got
lots of friends on there respected
colleagues so you know I was expecting
some good good comments so I thought I'd
pick out a few you can see I've got a
few there but I thought I'd show you
some of the good ones this is from Nick
Johnny chanson a world-class village
idiot with deep expertise in
circumventing the best features of type
safety
programming languages I think you can
tell how this is gonna end up dan
possesses all five fingers on each hand
leading one to suspect he's not from
really around here she's done I have
been Jonathan Shannon is the gdpr of
brexit when it comes to code reviews I
don't even know what I means but you
know there we go
Niall Merrigan known for using a spell
checker on his home name now if if you
don't know Niall is one of the
co-organizers of MDC so I was kind of
expecting something you know a bit
respectful something nice and warming
about me people will go yeah yeah but no
obviously not you know he went for that
so knowing that Niall is a security
expert I thought I would start changing
the way I write my applications just to
kind of get my own back and and make him
sweat so all my applications now are
going to be case insensitive eight by
eight to zero to nine passwords that's
fine
I'm not going to use any HTTP because
well it's expensive and you know I don't
get paid a lot so here we go I am NOT
going to encode any of my HTML output so
if somebody sends in a script tag in
their input what can go wrong of course
I'm going to put my connection strings
into github with blank passwords that's
that's fine nothing nothing to worry
about there in any you know sequel that
I do sequel promises for wimps is I've
heard about this injection thing but
anything is going to take off so there
we go
hopefully Niall will sweat no so here's
a proper grown-up professional slide my
name is Jonathan Shannon I am a software
developer I am a core contributor Nancy
anyone used Nancy before good
I wrote the Omni sharp sublime plugin so
way back when when Omni shop first came
back I was there in the trenches so if
you use omni sharp for the ESCO today
with c-sharp that's where it all comes
from
I'm the author of Carter which we'll go
into later
I'm a former Microsoft asp.net MVP I'm a
husband father around nice guy I work
for a company called VQ communications
so thank you to them for letting me come
here and talk to you majority of our
team work remotely in the UK we're about
to release a new major release of our
product in the next couple of weeks this
runs on dotnet core we ship it in
kubernetes it runs photographs database
uses Redis as a cache uses elasticsearch
pretty much every buzzword you can think
of we're kind of using that Miki was
also a company that paid for Nancy to
get onto dotnet core a couple of years
ago so they're a good company to work
for if you aren't sending my code it's
that github calm /j shannon i'm on
twitter twitter.com slash j Chanin and
my email is jonathan channel at
gmail.com so who uses solid in their
applications most people the solid has
been around for 10-15 years ever since
dotnet kind of came out and they paired
nicely and it's it's a design pattern
that most developers use they kind of
take that design principle they apply it
to their projects they then start a new
project they go are we need solid again
we need some IOC containers it cetera et
cetera it's kind of ingrained in
developers psyching and when junior
developers join the company they go how
do we do this coding stuff you gotta
where you need to solid this is what
you're going to do and in fact Microsoft
have recently released some application
guidelines whether you're writing docker
apps or dot nightcore apps and doing
funky things with that their underlying
recommendations is to use the solid
design principle now I must stay that
I'm not against solid what has happened
over the last few years ten years
solid and layered applications seem to
be joined together and they're kind of
synonymous in application design I'm not
against solid and in fact parts of solid
will be in the final solution that I'll
show you later on what I want you to
take away from the talk is that we want
to write simple clean understandable
code and no magic so who has seen
something like this before yeah we all
know so I came up against something like
this a while ago and scratch my head
felt holy moly and ran doctress on it
which is a profiling tool from JetBrains
and what it was saying was reflection
was being slow in our application and I
thought to myself well we don't use
reflection in our application so I felt
a bit more and said your constructors
are being slow ah I think I know what
this is I think this is our ioc
container because essentially what IOC
is doing underneath is analyzing your
types looking at the Constructors seeing
the types that your constructor needs
makes that then looks at that type and
goes all the way down a tree to
constructing your types so what did we
do well obviously we swapped ioc
container problem solved in fact we did
swap sea container and it did
work but we did more so we analyzed how
our dependencies were being used in our
classes we took these dependencies and
whether they were used maybe just once
in the whole god-like class it took
specific classes and took the s out a
solid and made very specific classes
consolidated the payer injected the
dependencies that only we needed for
that function and generally tried to
keep it simple
so at this point I want to discuss why I
decided to do the talk I'd watched the
talk by Greg young call Dateline
of code it was something I was well
aware of but never got around to
watching but after dealing with our
previous slide it kind of hit home and
what Gregg was trying to say is try and
think about the problem you are trying
to solve don't automatically go to a
design principle think about the problem
a modern software development is a
complicated thing and things are getting
harder and getting more distributed and
we kind of have to think how we
construct our applications
now front-end development is an easy
target years ago we had something like
this
we had an HTML page with some CSS and
JavaScript it would post to the back end
and it would insert some data into the
database everything is fine move on a
few years and we end up with something
like this I don't like how we how did we
end up like that we've now got
dependency injection in our front end
we've got micro services in our front
end I don't know how we got to this but
I think what the JavaScript developers
did that they looked at the backend and
thought all these guys know what they're
doing that's there's bung in our in our
JavaScript must be good but essentially
wide all that is doing is magic and
we're trying to avoid magic so
especially in Norway you don't want to
use magic because you will upset this
guy any Vikings fans good good so we
have some points to code by if you see a
design pattern on the internet and think
I like to look at this design pattern
don't just shove it in your application
thinking yes it's good this will work
this will fix stuff it probably won't
that's called CV driven development
we're trying to add points to your CV
but in the long term you're making your
code probably more untain about
don't take on dependencies that can be
done in a few lines of code he remembers
left pad took down half the internet
when some guy wrote a library which had
about three lines of code in if you've
got three lines of code put it in your
application you don't need that the same
for frameworks if you've got a few
classes that need to do a few things
you're not going to need all the bloat
of a framework to do that if you have an
IDE extension to help you write and
understand your code base your code base
is not a simple code base something is
wrong object relational mapper is my
favorite if your application needs a few
lines a few rows of data out of the
database
why are you installing entity framework
and then hibernate to do that learn SQL
all you need is selectable from table
where ID is one stick dapper in front of
that maybe and you've got an object in
c-sharp if you flip that and you're
doing an application which is doing some
intensive data crunching maybe and
you've got a complex domain what makes
you think and the framework and then
hibernate is going to understand your
domain more than you do learn SQL I was
at a job a while ago and they used
entity framework I managed to avoid
using entity framework because I'd heard
lots of bad stories about it but they
were using it and they had this query
and it was taking four minutes to run
this query so it seems a long time
that's it's gonna have a look delve
under the hood and see what entity
framework is producing it was producing
this
pretty nice huh so I rewrote that query
using SQL and using dapper about four
minutes became four seconds learn SQL
please another point an old quote but
always a good one
always code is if the guy who ends up
maintaining your code will be a violent
psychopath he knows where you live this
is an old quote but very very good if
you have to explain the intricacies of
your codebase through junior developers
now you have to stand on one leg jump to
the left jump to the right to make it
work
alarm bells should be ringing so today
we are going to go through a few demos
we're going to start off with a
traditional solid layered web
application that hopefully everybody
recognizes well get on their news
mediator library which will allow us to
consolidate our dependencies and our
behavior in our application once we've
done that we're going to remove mediator
because we don't need that dependency
and then our final solution will be a
functional approach we will remove our
ioc containers and are mocking libraries
so demo time now there's quite a lot of
code in these projects and chrissy
tweeted me saying why would i want to
sugarcoat things
the biggest problem in development in
these days these demos that contain only
10% of the code you will need for a
production ready version so this code is
a fully running API which returns films
so we're going to go through a lot of
the code so hopefully you will enjoy it
okay
so we have our traditional project does
everybody recognize the controllers
repository services kind of design so if
we look at our film controller we have a
film service injected into it we then
have our route which goes and gets an
ienumerable of films this returns the
film service dot lists films if we look
at that this returns what the film
repository returns if we go and look at
that the demo purposes it returns an
in-memory list of films obviously in
reality this would be some sort of
database lookup if we then go and look
at our film get by ID again it calls the
film service passes the ID from the root
if the film is null it returns a 404
otherwise it returns the film if we go
and look at our this film by ID method
you'll notice it uses some dependencies
which were injected into the service so
it uses a film repository to go and get
the film by ID the demo purposes we just
returned a film object then uses the
director service to go and get the
director for the film it uses a cast
member service dependency to go and get
the casts for this film it signs the
properties and returns the film creating
a film so we check that our validation
has passed otherwise we return a bad
request then it goes and cools the film
service not create film if that throws
for any reason we return a 403 otherwise
we return a 201 if we go and look at the
create film method this has a permission
service dependency this checks if the
user is valid if it's not it throws
otherwise it does some special Megacorp
business
validation otherwise it passes it down
to the repository and saved it to the
database
similarly with updating a film we have
an ID of the film it's going to update
checks whether the model state is okay
if the film service Update film throws
it will return a 403 otherwise it will
return a 204 if we look at the update
film again it checks is that a valid
user do some special business validation
use the repository to go and get that
film update that film with the incoming
films properties and then pass that to
the repository to update the database
same with the delete method passes it to
the film service turns a 403 if throws
otherwise a 204 that also does a valid
user check otherwise it passes it to the
repository everybody happy with that so
to test something like this what we tend
to do is have something that looks like
this so our first test should get list
of films this goes and gets an HTTP
client it takes an optional film service
as a method argument and it says if
that's know create a fake instance of
that film service if the film service
lists films is called make sure it
returns an array of films with
Goodfellas in it if the film service
lists film by ID is called return a film
with Blade Runner we then create an
in-memory webserver we register our
dependencies we set up MVC we set up our
validation and we return our client we
then go and execute a request to go and
get some films we then read the body
back and then we assert that Goodfellas
was returned
same with should get film by ID we're
gonna create the client we execute
request for film ID one and we assert
the Blade Runner has come back we then
do a test for a 404 so if the film is
returned as null we get a 404 so we
create a fake we tell that fake to
return null if number one is passed in
we get our client we execute a request
and we get a 404 back creating a film we
do a check to see if we get a 400 we
create a client we create a film with an
MD name because our validation is going
to be checking that we've got a name we
execute that post and we get a 400 back
so this is checking that our controller
code is doing these checks inside them
we then have a test to check that a 403
is returned when an invalid user tries
to create a film again we create our
fake we tell the fake that when a create
film is called and an instance of film
is passed in we're going to ignore it
but we're going to tell it to throw an
invalid operation exception so we get
the client we pass in a film with a name
so it passes our validation we post that
it throws and we check we get a 403 in
return if everything is okay we should
get a 201 in response the same for
updating a film as before with the post
create an MD name do a put check we get
a 400 same with throwing an exception if
we update a film with an ID of 1 we make
a request with a valid film of ib 1 we
should get a 403 in return and if all is
well we get a 204 and the same with
deleting for everything is OK we get a
204 if we tell our fake film service to
throw when delete film is called
we get a 403 bag we can also do some
tests maybe for the film service itself
we create a fake into the film
repository we're going get in the film
service by passing in fake film
repository direct the service cast
member service etc etc we own create our
system under test which is our film
service we then execute list films and
we knee then check that list films on
the repository was called there's some
reasons why you might do that I think
you probably want to do some integration
tests on your repository itself this
doesn't you know it doesn't hinder it in
any way but I think there's probably
better ways to test but that's hopefully
some sort of application that you guys
and girls recognize so what we're going
to do now is move to a mediator design
and this time we arrange our project
structure is slightly different we use a
features folder so all our films logic
queries etc go under films anything to
do what directors and so on and so on so
here we have our films controller under
our films folder we then have our create
film delete film etc under folders there
what we inject in our film controller
here is a mediator and I mediator
instead of a I film service if we look
at our routes to get the films we create
a list films message we then send that
to mediator a mediator knows it's going
to return an ienumerable of film now
mediator works in the way that you have
a message and a message Handler and your
message handler is the single
responsibility to return whatever is
defined so if we go and look at our list
films handler
that's it it's a class whose
responsibility is to return an
ienumerable of film before we had our
controller our service our repo this is
all we needed it to return in reality
this would have some sort of sequel
connection or whatever and return the
films but for our demo purposes this is
what it's doing in our startup class we
would register that this film's message
and this film's message handler go
together and our ioc container will
resolve all that for us the same with
getting a film by ID we list we create
the list films by ID message passing the
ID send it to mediator and again if the
film returned is null we return a 404
otherwise we return the film if we go
and look our handler for that you can
see we've got a few more dependencies we
have a list film by ID query I get
director by ID query and get cast by
film ID query but we don't inject any
permissions service because we don't
need it in this class but if you look at
the handle method it's exactly the same
as we had before it goes and gets the
film it goes and gets the director it
goes and gets the cast it assigns it to
the film and we return the film so
nothing's really changed there we've
just consolidated into classes the same
with a post we check that the model
state is okay if it's not we return the
400 otherwise we create a create film
message we send that to mediator if that
throws we return a 403 otherwise we
return a 201 the same as before if we
look at our create film message handler
this injects an i valid user query
object
but the handle method is the same it
checks if the valid you can check if the
user is valid if not it throws otherwise
it does it's special Megacorp business
validation and then writes to the
database the only slight difference is
it returns a unit mediator doesn't have
the concept of void
it uses unit to represent a void
it always wants you to return something
same with a put logic is the same but we
create an update fill message we passed
the ID we passed the film if it throws
we return 403 otherwise of 204 we inject
I'll list film by ID query and valid
user query objects is the user valid do
some business validation go and get that
film by its ID which is in our message
we update the existing film we write to
the database with a new film and return
in the same with the delete so how do we
test something like that we have our
features folder still in our test
project we have our test class we still
have our test that says should get a
list of films but here we fake a
mediator we say when our fake mediator
dot send method is called with a list
film's message return an array of films
which is good fella's on it we go and
get the HTTP client we execute the
request and we check their good fella's
is returned in the response same width
should get film by ID we create a fake
mediator again we say when dots and is
called with a-list films by ID message
it returns Blade Runner we execute the
request and we check their response
the same again for 404 we tell it to
return a null when at list films by OD
messages pass to it we then check we get
before I 4 on response the same for
creating a film we check that validation
fails and we should get a 400 a response
but everything is pretty much the same
as before we've consolidated our classes
we can still fake mediate if we have to
and we can check our responses so now
we've consolidated our classes we can
remove mediator because it's a
dependency that we don't need what it's
doing can be written in our own code so
if we go and look at our films
controller now instead of injecting an
eye mediator it's injecting a handler we
go and get our list of films but this
time we create a list films command
it could be lists films message if you
like I called it come on you know naming
is hard but we pass our command to the
handler we say to the handler we're
gonna pass you a list films command and
we expect an ienumerable of films in
return if we go and look at that what
this is doing it's similar to what
mediator was doing it's essentially
finding a handler for the types as
startup we register these handlers like
we would do with mediator so this I knew
Miraval of I command handler is injected
into this class we just said we want
lists films command so it says first or
default where the generic argument is of
type T so it should get our list films
command handler if that's no throw but
otherwise how
don't execute and then cast the response
back to an ienumerable of film okay so
if we go and look but it's exactly the
same as before it returns our array of
films but we've managed to reduce our
dependencies
the same with our films by ID passes it
to the handler if it returns now we get
a 404 in response otherwise a 200 if we
look at the handler for that again we
inject our dependencies to get the film
we have our director dependencies and we
have our cast members queries but the
logic in the method is the same as
before we go and get the film if it's
now we return otherwise we get the
director get the cast members sign up to
the film and return same with the post
we check our validation we create we
create a create film command and pass it
the film that goes into our handler if
it throws we catch it return a 403
otherwise a 201 but the logic is the
same as before checks the users valid
Dassin validation saves it to the
database and we can test this in the
same way as before
so I'd heard people talking about losing
their ioc containers and mocking
libraries and i couldn't quite grasp it
i was to scratch my head i don't know
how they're gonna do this this is gonna
end up quite messy and that was until i
read a blog post by Mike Hadley you
might know Mike Hadlow from easing that
queue he wrote a library which talks to
RabbitMQ I think he runs a UK user group
but he gave these examples he have three
interfaces the first one I customer data
has get customers for customer report
which returns an ienumerable of
customers have an eye report builder
which has a create customer report takes
in a customer returns a report we have
an eye email interface with a send
method which takes a to address and a
body the implementation of that for demo
purposes as he returns some customers
his report builder implementation
returns a new report uses the customer
email and the report body is this is the
report body for the customer email for
demo purposes his email adjust calls out
to console.writeline we then use these
dependencies like so we inject them in
as we would normally in object-oriented
programming our run customers report
batch method uses our dependency to get
the customers it loops over them and
then uses our report builder create
customer report passes in the customer
to create the report and then sends the
email we were tested like this most
likely we create a mock or a fake of
these dependencies we create an expected
customer object and expect the report
body object we say for our fake customer
data when get customers for customer
port is executed return an array of
customers with our expected customer
object for a report builder fake we say
when create customer report is called
passing the expected customer that we
created earlier returned a new report
with that expected customer objects
email and report body variable we then
passed these fakes into our reporting
service that we saw before we run that
method and we verify that the email was
sent now Mike proposed a new way of
doing this and it was this a static
method who static everybody loves static
changes global state it's pretty
horrific but actually when you start
looking at what Mike's suggesting it's
actually pretty useful the only problem
with static statics is when you do
mutate global State what mike has done
is reduced pretty much 80% of the code
we had before but if you look at the
main body of our it's doing exactly the
same instead of having a class with
injected dependency we have a method
with method arguments those method
arguments are funks and actions
I'll get customer customers for customer
report is a func which returns an
ienumerable of customers we loop over
that custom those customers as before we
call create customer report which is a
func which takes in a customer and
returns a report and then we call send
email which is an action we can then
write tests for this we create our
expected customer object we create an
expected report body variable we then
assign the func we don't create any
mocks or anything like that we assign
the func and say return an array with
our expected customer object we assign
our create customer report func
to take in a customer and return a
report and passed in the expected
customers email and
expected reporting we create two
variables we then say in the send email
action that takes in to address and body
assign those to the variables we then
execute our static method and pass in
those funks and actions and we can then
assert that those variables have been
assigned in the action pretty cool so
how do we do something like that in a
web application well hopefully I can
show you now so again we still have our
features folders we still have our film
controller but nothing is injected what
we have is something that still gets our
handler we execute our Handler and
return what it gives us that handler not
sure if you can see returns an
ienumerable of film our list film by ID
is still at handler that takes in an ID
our logic says if that is null we return
a 404 otherwise we return okay and that
film the same with a post the logic is
still the same we check that the
validation has passed if it hasn't we
return a 400 otherwise we execute the
handler and passing the film if that
throws we return a 403 otherwise we
return a 201 now if we go and look and
what these handlers actually uh-huh is
there are statics
our lists film handler is a funk which
should return an irony Miraval a film we
then have a constructor here which says
list films handler has nothing to pass
it in but we expect an ienumerable of
film in response and we passed that
across to our list films route handle
method if we look at that it's the same
as before we have a handle method which
returns our an ienumerable film we just
have this slightly different looking
class and sets up the phones imagine
this as your startup class where you
wire up all your dependencies our list
film by ID handler is a func which takes
an end and expects a film in return so
we assign that here we're taking the
film ID and we pass it to a handle
method which requires a film ID it
returned it requires a func which
returns a film by ID it returns it
requires a func which takes in an int
and returns a director and it takes in a
funk which takes in an int and returns
some cast members we can set that up
here for demo purposes we do it in
memory but in theory you could write
some SQL to do that here the same for
the update film handler that takes in a
film ID and a film we pass it across to
our handle method that requires the film
ID the film a func which returns a
boolean to say whether the user is valid
or not for demo purposes we are using
this highly efficient code here and it
also requires a list film by ID func
which we've got here and you'll notice
we've also used it up here so what we
could do is use that commented code up
there to share that share that logic the
same with the create and the delete
handlers they also use the valid user
check we could take that code
that's used in three places and put it
somewhere central and what we can do is
tidy that up a bit
rather than having scary-looking funks
and actions and we can use delegates and
it makes things look a bit prettier
doesn't it our list film by ID root
which has three four dependencies rather
than writing SQL in here and using
duplicated code we've separated they're
separated those in two classes
themselves so we have a list films by ID
query which we can reuse we can use that
in the update film here and we can use
it there same with our valid user check
we've now got it in a class which we can
call execute on and it's still execute
the same code so how do we test
something like this well what we do is
we still have our features folders we
have our tests we still creates our
in-memory webserver we set up MVC our
validation create the HTTP client and
return so we have our test should return
400 on invalid data what we're doing
here is we're not using any mocking
libraries we are assigning that funk and
we are saying create film handler takes
in a film we call our create film root
dot handle method which takes in that
film but it also requires a valid user
delegate something it returns a boolean
fraud test
we're just saying you know not users
valid and we return a true we then pass
in a film with no name so our validation
will fail we execute that request and we
check then we've
400 and responds the same with the 403
check I'll create film handler takes in
a film and passes it to the create film
route handle method takes in the film
but this time we're going to say no user
it's not valid we know that the code in
there is going to throw so therefore we
should get a 403 in return same with if
everything is okay we assign our create
film handler takes in a film we say yep
the user is valid we pass in a valid
film with a valid name we post that
across and we check that we get 201 in
response I should get film by ID this is
the one that took in three or four
dependencies before we assign the func
takes in an ID which then passes it to
our list film by ID root handle method
that requires an ID a list film by ID
delegate here we assign Bladerunner
it also requires something that returns
a director and something that returns
cast members we're not creating any
fates here we're just assigning funks
we're assigning delegates actually we're
using c-sharp two or three code nothing
new nothing fancy
back to basics but we can execute a
request and we can check the Bladerunner
is returned in the same with the 404 we
can say make this return null if that
returns no we know our controller is
going to check for that and therefore we
should get a 404 so now we've hopefully
improved our architecture there's less
magic involved but we still have our web
framework and we have something that
looks like this
we have attributes bloody everywhere
what are they doing okay we can infer
what it's doing the route okay that's a
string that defines the route allow
anonymous I assume is allowing anonymous
users but what's that doing underneath
is it inspecting headers or objects I
don't know we then have to give an
attribute to say this is a controller
well we've told it's a controller here
why do we need more attributes here what
is this magic doing creating a film okay
it accepts a post but what is that doing
underneath oh it produces JSON and it
consumes JSON what's this doing it also
returns a to i1 if everything is okay
what does produces response type dude I
don't know one of my developers has come
along said all I need to do some special
logic for this method and put an
attribute on there what is that doing so
in the words of Mick Dundee and that's
not a framework this is a framework so
anyone who used Nancy before yep so a
while ago I decided to write Carter it
was originally called Botwin but I
confuse people and it uses the same
routing style as Nancy but Nancy uses
Owen so it can run on multiple platforms
multiple hosts but the problem with Owen
and asp.net core now is performance a
request comes in it goes across to Owen
which converts the HTTP context to a
dictionary Nancy takes that dictionary
creates its own request object passes it
through to the module comes back out as
a response updates the dictionary
updates the context and back out we go
there's a performance problem so I
thought I wonder if we can take the
routing middleware in asp.net core and
consolidate that into classes too
to find roots in our application turns
out we could but with the same idea is
Nancy Carter is explicit in what it's
doing if you need authorization
authentication on your roots you can use
this dot requires authentication we
don't need an attribute we can debug
that easily we can also define our
methods using the verbs in line and pass
that to a method if needs be it doesn't
have to be a method it could be a funk
that's all this is doing you do this
don't get takes in a path and then you
can either have a request delegate or a
funk which takes in a request a response
object and a route data object and
expects and tasks in response so again
if we look at the logic it's exactly the
same but we're doing things slightly
different more carta like we get our
hand ax this returns an ienumerable a
film we then say context dot response as
json passing the film's that's going to
return our films as json and return a
200 we're not doing this dot okay object
being a bit more explicit the same with
this film by ID handler it takes an ID
we go and get the route data from the
route we then say ID is what we want we
cast it as an integer pass that into our
handler that returns a film object as
before if the film is null we return 404
otherwise we return the object is JSON
when updating a film we don't
have any attributes inside a method we
explicitly say go and bind and validate
the incoming request body and cast it as
a film if the validation result is
invalid we set the status code to four
to two we then say use some content
negotiation and write out some formatted
errors the model state equivalent errors
otherwise if everything is okay go and
get the handler go and get the ID off
the route and then use the result data
which is our film fall is okay return of
204 otherwise return 403 the same as
before
but we're being a bit more explicit in
our web framework and we test it in
exactly the same way as we did with MVC
we create our in-memory webserver we
assign the func we execute the request
and we assert the response
so it's in homework time cui demo code
that I mentioned earlier from Mike had
low is at his website go and check that
out
Gregg young also did a talk called the
art of destroying software
he said if you write code it takes
longer than a week to rewrite your code
was not simple enough take your code
delete it if it takes longer than a week
something's not right
mark seaman did a similar blog post it
said solid the next step is functional
and kind of highlighted similar to what
I showed today and what Mike showed in
his blog post brian Giesler also said
beyond solid the dependency elimination
principle try and eliminate your
dependencies greg young's eight lines of
code i suggest if you don't watched it
go and watch it it really is a good talk
and will make you think days afterwards
dan north did a presentation at PubCon
last year saying why every element of
solid is wrong so in conclusion should
you still use the layered solid approach
that's entirely up to you hopefully I've
shown you something today where you
thought oh that's going yeah there's
always talking about try it out and see
how you get on if it does work brilliant
what you can do is solve the next
problem and not worry about magic IOC
and things like that thank you for your
time the code is up on github if that's
where we're still pushing code cuz you
know Microsoft mm-hmm so yeah go and
check that out have a plain anyone sees
Troy hunt can you tell them I've got its
hat my children I've been watching a
film recently called the greatest
showmen they have a song on there called
the greatest show
and these thing has been brilliant this
week glad I could come so I'm going to
play you out that thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
we do your warning